Michael B Jordan and Lori Harvey call it
quits after just over a year of dating
[Music]
[Music]
it's officially over for the power
couple a source tells ET 25 year old
Lori and 35 year old Michael quote were
at different stages in their lives the
two of them are trying to move on but
they're both heartbroken and upset
the pair was never shy about sharing
their love and packing on the PDA on
Instagram but Lori has since deleted all
old photos with the Black Panther actor
from her page since news broke of the
romance ending it seems like the pair is
leaning on their Pals for support here's
Lori catching up with her pal adjusting
sky at a baby shower over the weekend
appearing to be in good spirits while
posing with mom-to-be Kristen Crawley
meanwhile it's Guy's Night for Michael
but he appeared to have different energy
and eyewitness tells ET the actor
attended game two of the NBA
championship series looking quote a
little sad and unenthusiastic oursaurus
adds he didn't mingle or take photos
instead he spent the night chilling with
corday he spoke to the Golden State
Warrior general manager Bob Myers and
said hi to G-Eazy what we'll miss most
about the stunning couple that
undeniable chemistry
[Laughter]
no no
no
[Applause]
Michael told ET that fun energy is
something that attracted him to Lori in
the first place
what is Michael B Jordan find very sexy
I think a sense of humor I think you
know the ability to laugh you know that
infectious feeling I think is I think
it's really really sexy so a small nice
smile and a life and a sense of humor is
uh is really sexy to me well I see why
you found who you found then because she
has all of those all those things
absolutely actually very funny a lot of
people don't know that about it yeah
she's really funny the split news sent
the internet into a frenzy with fans
weighing in all over on social media I
think I'm a pretty lovable guy actually
even Lori's dad Steve Harvey addressed
the breakup on his radio show saying
he's team Laurie one thousand percent
still Steve says that Michael is a cool
guy and people break up all the time and
when he spoke to E.T last year he made
it clear he's a big mbj fan this guy is
is not a representative
he is genuinely who he who he looks like
he is I mean like it threw me off at
first because he was so kind you know I
figure okay this is the game right but
it wasn't man this dude was sincere
and he's proven to be a really really
good good guy man I mean look I'm
pulling for it you know I'm pulling for
them
[Music]